Good morning John, I got to do
something very weird this year.
I got put into a room with 4 other
dorks, and we together judged the
Nikon small world photography
competition.
Photomicrography
I should say.
Not photography.
Beautiful pictures, using microscopes.
We talked about technique, how
clever and skilled someone had
to be to capture the image. We
talked about beauty, how did the
images make us feel. And we
talked about story, what did the
image tell us about the world? It was really fun, and happened
a while ago, but now finally the
results have been released
to the world.
So I get to give you
right now the top 10 best
microscopic images of 2021 as
judged by 4 experts and me.
Starting out with number 10, this is
a butterfly wing. There were a
lot of butterfly wings and that
makes sense because they are
absolutely amazing.
Something about
the composition of this one,
with that huge brown vein and that
one misplaced scale shot this
one to the top 10. Number 9 is one that I
personally fought for.
This is a daphnia, it’s a tiny crustaceon
and they are not chill.
I have followed them with
my own microscope and getting
an image this sharp with this
much color contrast is amazing.
But in addition to that, this little
water flea is covered in, I think
vorticellas, single celled filter feeder
that eats some of the same stuff
as the daphnia.
And then up in there,
those little blue dots-- those
are baby daphnia.
Number 8 is a cross section of a
mouse intestine, which we all liked
because it’s a reminder that a
lot of the diagrams in anatomy
textbooks are simplifications.
The way fluorescence microscopy is used
here really lets you see how the
surface area is maximized in the intestine
which increases nutrient absorption.
Number 7 is the head of a tick, we
were all just really pleased when
we saw beautiful images of things
that we generally find disgusting.
Number 6, these are the blood vessels of a mouse’s brain.
And as impressive
and fascinating as it is, I think I
primarily liked this one as a piece
of art that I would absolutely hang on my wall.
Number 5 again, we love the gross stuff. This is the proboscis of a house fly,
and maybe you didn’t want to see
that but also it’s really amazing!
And the more we looked
at it the more we loved it.
In fourth, we have a single sensory
neuron of an embryonic rat.
Again, we’re used to these oversimplified diagrams of neurons with a couple dozen branches
at max, but neurons can have thousands
of dendrites that connect to tens
of thousands of other cells. And now it’s time for our top 3.
In 3rd place, this leg claw of a louse.
We really did hit as many annoying bugs as we could.
I like this one because
the tracheae which are the holes that
they breathe air into their bodies through,
they’re like the wormholes that Bill and
Ted would fly through in Spacetime.
Like the whole thing just looks like
a galaxy, but it’s a louse. Speaking of galaxies, in second place
this one is a bunch of neurons
that were put on two sides of a barrier
with tiny channels in it, and then because
the nuclei couldn’t fit through those channels,
the axons of the neurons did.
And they meshed together into this
image that absolutely looks like some
kind of science fiction megastructure.
And finally, what beautiful, weird,
otherworldly thing did we choose for our
number 1 image of the year?
Was it something
maybe you’d never seen before, some
new discovery, some tiny organism
that only scientists pay attention to?
No.
It is a leaf.
I believe it is the underside
of a leaf of the southern live oak, shown
in a way that completely reshapes my
understanding of something so simple.
This image, which is the result of stacking
over 200 different images focusing
on different planes, shows 3 different
vital leaf structures: stomata in purple,
trichomes in white, and veins in blue.
It’s an oak leaf, alive and complex and mysterious like I never imagined.
Thanks so much to Nikon Small World
for putting this together and providing
those images for this video.
There were so many other amazing
images which you can go see if you
just go to nikonsmallworld.com. I think there were something like 100
total images that we have some
kind of distinction.
It was a wonderful way to spend 2 days, thanks to all of the other judges and everybody
who submitted their work to the
competition.
It is a reminder of how amazing our world is, and
how amazing our tools for observing it are,
and a reminder of how amazing people are who
observe this world in all of the different
ways we observe it.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.